elephants over there Nelson oleraya
drives us through his community Wildlife
Conservation Area on the edge of the
Maasai Mara game reserve five years ago
this land was an overgrazed Dust Bowl
where people had put up fences that
blocked Wildlife from their traditional
migratory routes Community Elders had a
big idea they took down the fences
pulled their land and now leave side by
side with Wildlife the community
was facing a free fall
in loss of land
so when we came in we had to get rid of
25 kilometers long lines of fences
it's High season here for tourists many
are heading to Maasai Mara to watch the
great wildebeest migration millions of
animals come from the Serengeti Game
Reserve in Tanzania to breed and Grace
but for many years local communities
have often been excluded from the
tourist dollars so the national
Conservancy decided to do things
differently we were wary
about approaching
those institutional funders that funds
Fortress conservation
because then they will change our
narrative
and we wanted to Pioneer a model that is
community-led their vision is ambitious
they want to create one of the longest
Wildlife corridors from acai Mara
through other reserves and onto the
Serengeti people who live in areas like
this one say they want to be more
involved in conservation efforts and
that's why it's so important for them to
have this community conservances and
they are thriving Jack Ole Monico says
his family set aside land for the
protected area living standard
our standard of living is improved we've
put aside money for our children's
education through a bursary fund when
times are hard especially during a
drought community members dip into their
contributions to help provide food and
other basic Commodities
tourists often stop over at the Village
to to sample the traditional way of life
this is not the only Community
Conservancy in Kenya but people here
believe that National eye has set the
pace for other conservation initiatives
which they say can only be good news
Catherine soy Al Jazeera National
Conservancy Kenya
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera